h würdest du gern kleinen Tripp um die
Welt mit mir machen kan im Ernst sag ja
Kumpel von den Machern von das ist ja
voll
superkmen Rennen durch drei Länder und
nur ein Team kann
gewinnenen was war he ihre Strategie
warte bag
danncesig l euch ein zu einem Rennen
rund um die Welt willkommen in
London ist der Amerikaner aber was für
ein sie sprechen keine
Fremdsprachen sie hat Angst dass du du
verhungerst aber dann finden sie heraus
dass Ihnen bei diesem Rennen jemand ans
Getriebe willning McQueen muss
aufgehalten
werden durchhalt McQueen Finn MCM
britischer geheimdien ich bin
agentiftww ihr Anfänger werd ganz klar
bevor wir brauchen deine Hilfe du Brast
meine
Hilfe wichtig ist nicht
auffallen das glaube ich jetzt
nicht
er ist ein bisschen aufgeregt wie es
aussieht
h tarnungsprogramm aktiviert hey jetzt
mach einen bayerischen Truck aus mir
wahnsinn da gehe ich gleich zum
reifenplatteln